各位觀眾朋友大家好,我是阿雅,歡迎回到 GlobalSight
在上一集的節目,我們 Sean 幫我們洗刷了對韓股的刻板印象
那今天我們很榮幸能夠再次邀請他來和我們聊聊韓股怎麼佈局
讓我們歡迎大華銀投信指數量化部門的主管 Sean
Sean 您好
各位觀眾朋友大家好,我是大華銀投信量化部門指數主管郭修成 Sean
富邦政證新戶優惠來囉
開戶急證 500 毛幣
完成指定任務再領 200 毛幣加 500 手續費抵用金
還有星宇航空布拉格商務艙雙人機票等你抽
心動不如行動 火速開戶做任務囉
那Shang 既然我們確認HBM是AI時代的剛性需求
那投資組合上全球科技巨頭這麼多
臺股也有臺積電
那為什麼現在您反而會建議大家
要把一部分的目光留到這個韓國股市呢
我想投資AI的話
大家如果只是上網搜尋你想投資AI
你很有可能會投資到一些題材相關的股票
或是一些可能邊緣受益股
你真正投資AI
你可能投資不到最核心的一個部分
那當然目前AI的一個浪潮
我想說是延燒到HBM
那當然你是挑到
最核心的一個股市去投
那當然就是韓股
不過對於我們一般投資人來說
去富爾多開戶買韓股好像很複雜
更別說挑個股了
那我們知道美國有S&P500
代表美國的門面
那韓國有沒有類似的總指標
可以讓我們一眼看懂
輕鬆參與呢
韓國Cosby50
它就是代表整個韓國的一個
經濟體的可以說是縮影
那它就是一個韓國的門面
那當然它除了大家所熟悉的三星
那可能裡面有一些LG
大家也可能有聽過
那當然SK海力士
它也是最主要我們目前的一個主角
那當然還有一些其他的
就像我們臺灣50裡面有一些金融股
他們也有韓國的金融巨頭
OK也有汽車
現代跟KIA
那再來是大型的通路的一些零售的一個股票都在裡面
所以投資韓國這樣子COSB50
你就等於算是整個投資韓國整個經濟的一個縮影
那聽起來呢
就是把韓國最強的50支經濟目綁在一起
不過我們既然要投資
我們還是得要看看這是基因能生多少顆蛋
那除了前面講的AI跟HBM之外
這個COSB50指數還有哪些重要產業
那可以值得投資人來關注呢
我想COSB50裡面除了
所謂AI相關的一個產業
接下來我們要關注的
大概是整個韓國股市的
它整個是國家隊的一個
政策的一個做多
大概是第一個引擎
當然我剛提到
就是說AI跟HBM的浪潮
這是可能是短中期
韓國股市最主要的推力
第二個引擎是
以前的韓國股市
可能在配息
或是Value Up的一個提升
沒那麼多著重
但是韓國政府已經算是
有指示他們的一些財閥
希望可以改善這些
譬如說註銷庫場股
或是增加你們的股票的配型
你讓這個AI的革命的紅利
可以散發到韓國的普羅大眾
他們政府在整個經濟的宏觀角度上面
一個最主要的政策
當然我覺得也是一個很不錯的一個政策
因為畢竟如果你的
AI的一個工業革命紅利
只是集中在少部分的產業
或是他們常提到的財閥
那可能就跟以前的
韓戰之後的一個工業革命
沒有什麼太大的不一樣
真正的普羅大眾
還是沒有辦法享受到
AI革命所帶來的紅利
那再來第三個就是近期
大家也知道他們到美國去發行ADR
成績跟價格其實都不錯
甚至溢價
盤中可能溢價超過
可能有到達三四十的溢價
我講的是ADR跟韓國股市的溢價
那當然大家會想要提到說
那這樣子我可不可以進去套利
當然一般人都會這樣想
但是在ADR跟韓國股市
就像我們的臺積電的ADR
他們中間的轉換有些限制
它不是這麼的自由
所以在套利的空間其實是少之又少的
在如果是一般的Retail Market
是很難去做到這件事情
但是如果你反過來看的話就是說
竟然國外的投資者
對於你SAK海力士的評價
竟然可以溢價這麼高
那你反觀直接去投資韓國股市
相當於是用比較便宜的一個部分價格
去做投資
那接下來就是執行面的問題
很多觀眾朋友現在可能已經拿出手機
準備看怎麼下單
不過Sean我們還是要去研究
怎麼直接買個股
還是透過ETF來參與會比較聰明
那在兩者操作上有什麼差異呢
我想投資上面有分
分散投資跟集中投資
或是你是價值型投資
或是成長型投資
每個人都有自己習慣的一個投資方式
但是如果以ETF的角度來講
當然第一首要是什麼
分散風險
不要把所有的籌碼都集中在一顆雞蛋上面
你應該是一籃子裡面的一個風險
它可以達到平均的一個分散的一個效果
我想這是我們發行ETF最主要的精神之一
在ETF的裡面你可以很分散的去做投資
我講的就是說你可能設計上面
可以用權重很分散
或是市值加權的一個設計
那這是兩種不同流派的
我們做出這樣的工具
讓投資人在不同的景氣循環
你去用那個工具去做投資
這是ETF發行商最主要的精神之一
以我們ETF來說的話
如果投資韓國
你可能一般投資人
沒這麼懂韓國的股市
當然你就是從ETF下手
是最好的
如同剛剛經理所說到的
小孩子才做選擇
那成熟投資人
就是可以用ETF一網打盡
那我們最後想要再請教
雖然韓股看起來潛力無窮
但每一種工具都有適合的體質
你認為什麼樣類型的投資人
適合把COSB50
納入自己的資產配置當中
那操作上有沒有策略可以提醒大家呢
AI的浪潮我剛說的
主聲段剛開始
那我相信很多投資人可能還沒有上車
或是正主要上車COSB50
第一個它是屬於AI浪潮的一個
主聲段的其中一個商品
那當然它的韓國的一個本益比
或是什麼相對於其他估值比較低
所以這是不錯的一個選擇
那怎樣的投資適合這樣的商品呢
第一個因為它是COSB50
那50檔裡面三星跟海力士
它又是佔的權重相當高一點
就是我剛剛提到的
分散投資跟集中投資裡面的
比較偏向集中投資的ETF
當然它的波動會跟三星跟海力士的波動
比較有關聯
所以它的波動會相對其他
可能等權重的ETF還要來得大
你本來就在投資債券的一種
比較保守型的投資人
你當然可能就會放的資產配置
當然會少一點
你當然不能不投資AI
當然你可能自己在資產配置上面的權重
可能就要自己去琢磨
再來另外一方式就是
比較忙碌或是我還沒有上車
但是AI的浪潮已經不知道要到哪裡了
你可以用什麼方式
定期定額的方式
因為它長期來說的話
它不會是很差的一個投資方式
所以總結來說我們算是把
把AI的一個浪潮裝進整個COSB
以韓國股市來說的話
就是把AI的浪潮裝進去一個ETF裡面
你買的ETF就是買的
整個AI的主聲段的一個浪潮
非常感謝Shion今天來到我們的節目
帶我們從更高的維度
來重新認識韓股跟HBM的戰略價值
想要跟上這波AI基建的重複行情
韓國COSB50
或許就是你不可或缺的科技拼圖
最後喜歡我的影片也不要忘記
訂閱按讚開啟小鈴鐺
我們下次再見
我們下次見 掰掰